like I don't think a guy should set out
to measure his own value by how many
times he can get laid I think that's
pathetic I totally agree with
that however it depends on what prison
we're looking at this high value
question through if we're looking at it
through the brutal realities of the
current modern dating Marketplace the
reality is that Leo or whoever other
ex-celebrity you want to put in his
place right he's going to get his end
away more than the average dude however
nice the average dude is I'm not saying
it's right and I'm not saying that is
the true measure of a man's worth
whether he can pull some you know clubs
the hoe or not but that is the brutal
reality of the way the sexual
Marketplace is now